so the reason women think like men are  trash is because we're all [ __ ] the  same ones maybe you  will how did how did you cheat  [Music]  have you ever cheated  maybe occasionally  unlimited Source yeah unlimited  source.com do you think they were  capping when they said they don't like  cheating most definitely they love bad  boys and what do I look like wow but why  do you see girls cheat more who cheats  more men or women  cheats more men or one man of course  have you ever cheated before yeah have  you ever cheated  have you ever cheated yes  this fault was your last break my ex's  why she cheated have you ever have you  ever cheated  why have you ever been cheated on yeah  how did you find out she got pregnant it  wasn't mine then why are there quotas  for women